je me souviens d'une d'une fois où je me
suis fait virer d'une émission juste
enin vraiment juste avant que ça
commence quoi donc céit un peu comme une
émission enfin com ave des chroniqueurs
et donc il m'appellent ils me font faire
une chronique et tout et il me disent on
adore ton humour et tout vas-y à fond je
vais comme d'hab enfin je sais pas et
donc j'écris ma chronique il me font
ouais on adore et tout puis après je
fais ma répè en plateau
et et là apparemment il y a le directeur
de la chaîne qui est qui qui découvre ma
chronique et qui dit visiblement c'est
hors de question qu'on diffuse cette
chronique et du coup ils sont venus me
me chercher j'étais au maquillage j'
j'étais à moitié maquillé ouais et il me
disent Laura euh on t'a commandé un taxi
en fait tu vas et du coup ouis c'était
j'étais avec tous les chroniqueurs je
vis bon bah je prends prends mes
affaires et je rentre et je rentre chez
moi c'était très euh direct et puis
voilà